you turned down the role of Gandalf you
were offered the role of Gandalf in the
in the Lord of the Rings series why I
turned it down I mean I thought maybe
three three or four years in New Zealand
I didn't I thought I there are other
countries I'd also like to visit before
I croak it's a big it's a big commitment
but still it's such a great part and oh
it was a marvelous part and I loved the
Lord of the Rings I grew up on it
actually I was it's a great great great
book and it became a great film and then
in plaited ian mckellen who was
absolutely marvelous in it and he
couldn't have been warmer which I might
not have brought to it I might have been
a little cold and imperious he was warm
and friend I hate the summit
[Applause]
spoken like a true actor yeah
what vermin we are oh yeah hey monix are
worse trim exams so you do you ever have
you ever thought about clearly not but
have you ever thought about retiring you
mean there's no reason are you
threatening me get through buddy you
don't have it kid no I have you ever
thought to yourself you ever thought to
yourself I might like to stop and do
something else me but clearly you love
acting I love it I'm not good at
anything else I completed a piano when
eight sheets to the wind I can I'm quite
good at you and me basically you're
attributing here long life and your
musical ability there alcohol everything
what it was
[Applause]
well apparently it was so much safer
than drugs yeah
this is the weirdest public service in
our kids drink alcohol
that's so much safer than drugs this has
been Christopher fun Wow okay I want to
retire I mean I I'm so sorry for people
who actually do want to retire it means
that they haven't loved what they do
yeah in life and and of course nothing
could be more marvellous and traveling
the world and being paid to do that I
mean that's extraordinary we're very
lucky group we are I'm not I am I
couldn't be my like what I do I it's and
it's the key it's the key to being happy
is like what you do absolutely and I
love it it's it's a it's a hobby as well
as a profession
you